artificial intelligence is changing the
way doctors treat patients in an
operating theatre this surgical robot
can do extraordinary things like helping
surgeons with complex keyhole operations
it's quite exciting to see robotic
techniques rolled out first of all from
an economic point of view just from a
surgeon's point of view you can set the
the system up far better to mean that
the stresses on the body are less which
hopefully will improve injury rates for
surgeons longer term which will mail us
to perform potentially push the
boundaries of surgery again just as
keyhole surgery did in the nineties
consultants like Jonathan Morton are
amongst a handful of surgeons trying out
the new technology it will soon be
rolled out in hospitals across the
country so how does it work
the robots allow surgeons to operate for
robotic arms which can be used to
control surgical instruments from a
computer it's lost actually the robot
doing the surgery per se is the surgeon
with the experience and the knowledge
that is telling the robot what to do the
NHS is delivering a 50 million pound
framework for robotic surgical equipment
which some are calling a mechanical
revolution for medicine these new robots
won't replace medics in our hospitals
according to the Royal College of
Surgeons they say doctors will remain in
control of operations but robots will
also play an important role although
using the technology may bring
advantages to the operating table
training is key says this leading
surgeon the robot is not going to be
taking over what surgeons do the robot
will become an integral part of the the
tools that surgeons use to carry out
operations on their patients now maybe
in the long-distance twenty years down
the line there may be some aspects of
surgery that aren't delivered by robots
say should we be afraid of robots
performing surgical procedures well the
manufacturers behind a technology claim
patients should be reassured because
they are safe the vision we have is that
we have built a system that
enable many many more patients to get
minimal access surgery and all the
benefits that that brings for them in
terms of reduce complications reduce
pain you know quicker return to work etc
and the the the aim is to put this
system is many hospitals worldwide as we
care it may seem hard to imagine but
this robot - and others alike might
possibly mean a difference between life
and death in operating theaters no
Philips Sky News